[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with stranger
things three already our clothes
everyone on the Internet is currently
wondering about the fate of one of the
show's biggest characters throughout
this video I'll be breaking down my
thoughts on what happened to Jim hopper
in the finale of the season as well as
what the post-credits scene actually
means there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't finished season three
of stranger things yet and I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into my fan theory on stranger
things three okay so stranger things
three is pretty similar in setup to the
prior two seasons with a lot of the
events unfolding in the very same manner
you know the drill by now normal kids
discover some cross-dimensional
creatures eleven unleashes their psychic
abilities and we finally feel like we
can rest
there's callbacks to movies and awesome
soundtrack and some teeters for next
time however unlike the prior two
seasons stranger things three ends with
the devastating death that leaves all of
the characters lives ripped apart during
the finale Jim Hoppa played by David
Harbor and Joyce journey to the mall to
attempt to close the doorway that the
Russians were trying to open to the
upside down it's paramount that the
device used to do this is destroyed
however hopper is apparently caught in
the blast when the machine implodes upon
itself though this sacrifice saves the
world the death is obviously a huge one
that completely tears the show apart for
the final few moments of the season we
pick up three months later and eleven
now has to go under the care of Joyce
who with the rest of the family is
moving away we see a newspaper report
that says hero Chief dies in fire and it
appears that Jim hopper is gone for good
along with Billy
however it's when we cut the
post-credits scene of the season that we
perhaps get confirmation that the death
may have not been everything we thought
you watch's two Russian guards feed a
prisoner to the demagogue in but before
doing their selection they pass a cell
and say no not the American to me this
is pretty obviously pointing towards
hopper being alive and there's actually
a lot of evidence to support that this
is the case the first comes with a death
scene itself in it we see Jim standing
after this
side of the Russian weapon and then he
gives Joyce a glance to let her know
that it's okay to overpower the machine
and destroy it
Joyce looks away and it's at this point
I believe that Jim flees the walkway
which is confirmed by the next shot of
the machine during its explosion in that
we can see Jim is not standing where he
was or even anywhere near the machine
when it explodes so he wouldn't really
be caught in the blast caused by it the
next bit of evidence comes from the fact
that the location we seen the
post-credits scene is actually the same
place that was shown during the
beginning of episode 1 when the Russians
were trying to open a portal to the
upside down personally I think this
shows that during the chaos at Stockholm
all Jim actually went through the
upside-down portal in order to escape
the explosion and came out at the other
side in Russia which is where he was
captured and put in a holding cell Jim
has been to the upside down before so he
has some knowledge of how to navigate it
and as he knew that Russia had been
trying to open a portal there probably
been [ __ ] towards it
the Russians have clearly been opening
more portals which is how they managed
to get access to the demagoguing
and Jim could have easily slipped
through the doorway into the Russian
installation of course we won't know if
all of this is for definite until season
4 rolls around but I can definitely see
this being highly likely especially when
Yuri watch the scene and know of the
Russians plans obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this fan theory
and if you agree with me or have a
completely different one comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of
season 3 which would be linked at the
end we're going to full detail over all
of the events I give more of my thoughts
on that enigmatic ending so it's
definitely worth checking out after this
video I also just want to let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
Avengers and game to one lucky winner
and all you have to do is like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
season 3 of stranger things in the
comments below the winner will be chosen
at random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from there
and whoever gets the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this and I hope you enjoyed the
video
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace